what a weekend despair confusion
disbelief surprise treachery and I'm
only talking about the historic New
England Patriots Super Bowl victory last
night never mind politics but a lot of
news in the political world as well this
story we did about Donald Trump
seemingly not being able to read well
has completely exploded it went nuts
nearly three million views on Facebook
nearly two hundred thousand views on
YouTube tens of thousands of comments
across all platforms about this and the
story is only growing not only do we
have even more evidence now that Donald
Trump would not pass a basic literacy
test we actually now have a document
which explains some of the normal and
common indicators that someone has
limited literacy and I'm going to
present all of this to you because I am
increasingly convinced that our
president has only a passing knowledge a
rudimentary a bill of a basic ability to
read and this is sort of a concern when
you're talking about the President of
the United States so first there's a
couple more things I want to show you
I'm not going to rehash all of the stuff
from last week all the different footage
and lots of different things that you
can check out by reviewing last week's
clip we have now some very very weird
footage from the inauguration day
morning worship service you'll remember
that Donald Trump and his wife and Mike
Pence and his wife went to a church to
apparently placate religious voters and
Mike Pence at one point hands Donald
Trump a pamphlet with the songs the ins
that were going to be sung there to
Donald Trump and when you look at Mike
Pence's face he looks visibly nervous
about handing Donald Trump something to
read it's very very clear that pence
doesn't seem super comfortable with this
and then as this entire charade
continues Donald Trump actually started
singing before the first verse started
clearly he doesn't really seem to know
exactly what's going on and you know
this could be because Donald Trump is
about being religious and just doesn't
know the songs but it also helps to
build this case that Donald Trump can't
really read and then this gets even
weirder when the first verse starts and
Donald Trump starts and stops singing he
doesn't really know what's going on he's
doing this thing that that is common of
people with low literacy which is he's
staring at the page without any visual
cues that suggests he's recognizing much
of what's written there and then at
another point Donald Trump actually
gives up and he puts his pamphlet away
and tells Melania to do the same of
course and no one else is doing this at
the time Trump seems genuinely mad that
he can't understand what it is that's
going on and puts his pamphlet away and
demands that his wife do the exact same
thing so again more and more of these
videos are surfacing where Donald Trump
just seems to have only a passing
recognition of the words and sentences
that are constructed in the English
language on different pieces of paper
and here's the really stunning thing
today it's come to my attention that the
Canadian police has what they call a low
literacy checklist document and this is
related to a program they call a
targeting crime with literacy I was
thinking as I review this how Canadians
of them targeting crime with literacy in
the u.s. we target crime with prisons
and guns not literacy and education in
any case take a look at it we have the
document here and as I went through this
document I realized that Donald Trump
matches the list of how we identify
people with limited literacy perfectly
this document pointing out keep in mind
that people who have trouble reading
writing and understanding verbal
information often try to cover up their
problem here are some of the signs that
may indicate a person has a low level of
literacy and again every single one of
these Donald Trump fulfills to a tee but
let's start with something that we've
observed with Trump for a while which is
that someone with limited literacy may
have difficulty telling a clear store
or sometimes might seem to talk in
circles that that way of thinking often
is correlated with a low literacy level
let me remind you this is just one
example of this exact phenomenon where
Donald Trump seems to talk in circles
and it's not clear what he's talking
about know what works me look having
nuclear my uncle was a great professor
and scientist and engineer dr. John
Trump at MIT good good genes very good
genes okay very smart the Wharton School
of Finance very good very smart you know
if you're a conservative Republican if I
were a liberal if like okay if I ran as
a liberal Democrat they would say I'm
one of the smartest people anywhere in
the world screw but when you're a
conservative Republican they try do they
do a number that's why I always sort of
went to Wharton was a good student went
there went there did this built the for
yet I have to give my like credentials
all the time hmm yeah it's all becoming
increasingly clear much of what we've
observed with Donald Trump maybe because
the guy can barely read another
indicator of a low level of literacy the
speaker may have stiff body language
when speaking again just one example let
me remind you of the following those
cases you realize what's happened it's
imploding as we say
some states have over a hundred percent
increase and 17 and I said this two
years ago seventeen is going to be the
bad year yeah another example from the
low literacy warning signs checklist
when asked to read or write something a
person with low literacy may make
excuses to avoid the task like for
example I can't read this because I
forgot my glasses this is exactly what
Donald Trump did in the video I showed
you last week from the deposition that
went viral first he doesn't read it want
to read it because it's too long then he
says he doesn't have his glasses again
look at this and tell me what you think
reading that you as the landlord are
entitled to get from the tenant in the
event of a tenant breach in the way of
damages I don't have my glasses I am
going to disadvantage I didn't bring my
glasses this is such a wall writing yeah
another example the speaker may look
dazed or uncomfortable when someone
gives them something to read they may
just appear to be staring at the page
without any indication that they're
actually reading or understanding what
is on the page I bring to you again
another exhibit from Donald Trump we can
have a bigger copy made of these pages
let me try let me just do it I have to
place on the record a hearty objection
again when they do write someone with
low literacy may make a lot of spelling
or grammar mistakes in their writing and
I proposed to you that we look at three
of Donald Trump's tweets one where he
wrote China steals United States Navy
research drone in international waters
rips it out of water and takes it to
China in unprecedented act remember
unprecedented a word that that he wrote
in a way that is not actually a word
also from Donald Trump another tweet
heading to Phoenix Phoenix misspelled
also another tweet from Donald Trump Ted
Cruz is totally unelectable if he even
gets to run born in Canada will loose
big to Hillary okay and of course we
know that Donald Trump usually is not
the one tweeting only tweeting
personally on occasion another indicator
of low literacy the low literacy person
may bring a friend or relative with them
who helps with both reading and writing
and I call your attention to Donald
Trump tweeting that he actually doesn't
write most of his tweets he dictates
them to someone else who posts them
continuing again Donald Trump meeting
every single bullet point from the low
literacy checklist of the Canadian
police initiative targeting crime with
literacy the speaker with low literacy
may give what seemed to be indirect
confused or irrelevant answers to
question I present to you Donald Trump
what would you set the federal minimum
doesn't have to be well I I would leave
it and raise it somewhat you need to
help people and I know it's not very
Republican to say well gimme gimme but
ten I would say ten I would say ten
with the understanding that somebody
like me is going to bring back jobs I
don't want people to be in that ten
dollar category for very long but the
thing is but let the states make the
data what they didn't have because you
could have a state that raises it to
fifteen yeah also individuals with low
literacy may not ask any questions at
all rather than revealing that they
don't understand what's going on another
hallmark of Trump are you familiar with
general Soleimani yes I did go ahead
give me a little go ahead tell me
he runs the codes forces yes okay right
do you expect the codes forces the
Iranian Revolutionary Guards code
Yeah right and then lastly individuals
who can't really read well will often
sign statements or legal documents that
they do not understand remember this
folks did you review the lease at all
before you signed it no how many leases
like this have you reviewed in your
career signed or reviewed really it not
too many I signed to hundreds and lastly
not that I need any video examples of
this individuals with low literacy may
try to give the impression may may give
the impression that they don't
understand the seriousness of a
particular situation
no clip needed there goes without saying
for Trump I want to remind you why is
this a big deal if an individual appears
to have low literacy it's more than just
a reading problem this impacts thinking
strategies this impacts how someone is
able to understand and potentially solve
problems what might sometimes be an
unusual or unproductive attitude towards
an issue can actually be the cause of a
literacy problem not only is Donald
Trump merely moderately literate we're
talking about a President of the United
States that
seems to be only slightly literate is
this a problem for anybody else the more
I look into this the more concerned I am
that the President of the United States
can barely read